les enfants les autres victimes
collatérales du conflit qui déstabilise
la centrafrique juvénal quatre ans a été
blessé par un char des casques bleus en
novembre dernier dans le centre du pays
le garçon a dû être amputé d'un bras et
d'un pied son père raconte m l'accident
s'est produit à 45 km de six buts
ce sont les soldats de la minus cas de
retour de bambari qui ont provoqué
l'accident
c'est là que mon fils a perdu son bras
et son pied avec ce qui lui est arrivé
vraiment je remercie dieu qu'il l'a
gardé en vie
ils étaient presque morts mais ce qui me
tracasse c'est son bras et son pied qui
l'a perdu cela me peine
je souhaite qu'il retrouve les âges de
son pied qu'il marche qu'ils se rendent
à l'école comme les autres enfants ce
sera vraiment bien la plus grande peine
ce sont son pied son bras ce sont son
pied son bras ce matin isaac emmène son
fils à bangui la capitale
dans ce centre national de rééducation
et d'appareillage c'est toute une équipe
qui attend juvénal le bras et le pied
amputé ce double handicap nécessitera le
port de prothèses ceux dont les
professionnels de ce centre ont
malheureusement l'habitude de faire
l'exercice de la charge
or en chercher un équilibre c'est
l'étape de décès mais n'ont laissé aller
statique
donc on cherche d'abord à un ça va porté
l'appareil et mettre l'enfant des bouées
s'est déchargée jusqu'à ce que l'on voit
si chargé la potée de l'assomption et
maintenant on va fait aussi l'alignement
de la prothèse par rapport à l'enfant
unique dans le pays
le centre accueille près de 50 personnes
par mois en majorité des enfants qui
viennent avec l'espoir de pouvoir
remarcher un jour on voit que ce que
nous faisons sa propre aux fruits et le
résultat est là
le rythme est soutenu pour les cinq
spécialistes du centre et les besoins en
orthoprothésiste élevé à travers le pays
et pour cause de nombreux centres
médicaux ne fonctionne plus conséquence
les blessés sont parfois amputés dans
l'urgence chaque jour ce centre de
bangui continue de prendre en charge de
nombreux enfants comme juvénal mais
aussi des adultes avec l'espoir de voir
le nombre de patients diminué